hola a todos bienvenidos a este tutorial
sobre cómo comenzar el aprendizaje a
distancia con khan academy sabemos que
con los cierres escolares la necesidad
de encontrar materiales para que
nuestros hijos sigan aprendiendo en casa
ha aumentado y queremos darle las
gracias a bank of america por ayudarnos
a aumentar nuestros servicios
rápidamente el objetivo de este tutorial
es ayudarte a ti ya tu hijo o hija a
comenzar a aprender en khan academy
además de compartir te donde encontrar
más recursos gratuitos de khan academy
para comenzar hablemos un poco sobre
khan academy
antes que nada aprender en khan academy
no cuesta nada somos una organización
sin fines de lucro y todas nuestras
lecciones y prácticas son gratuitas para
los estudiantes sus padres y maestros
cada academia es una fuente confiable
puedes confiar en nosotros porque
llevamos haciendo esto durante mucho
tiempo más de diez años con millones de
usuarios alrededor del mundo incluso
antes del cierre de escuelas
todos nuestros cursos de matemáticas
están alineados con él como un corte de
eeuu y nuestros otros cursos distintos a
los de matemáticas app e incluyen
material del common core y contenido
adicional además también tenemos cursos
alineados a los estándares educativos de
méxico y perú por ultimo khan academy es
flexible la aplicación principal de khan
academy que es de lo que hablaremos
ahora está disponible en versiones web y
oeste y android y para equipos de
escritorio siempre y en cualquier lugar
y está traducida a más de 40 idiomas
ahora entremos al tema de lo que
realmente significa aprender en khan
academy la pregunta que nos hacen con
mayor frecuencia es cómo puedo saber lo
que mi hijo debería estar aprendiendo
muchos padres no sabemos exactamente en
dónde se quedaron nuestros hijos justo
antes del cierre de escuelas y sin duda
no estamos acostumbrados a enseñar así
que lo primero que debemos hacer es
sentirnos orgullosos de que estamos
intentando sacar a nuestros hijos
adelante durante una época que tiene
muchas otras causas de estrés con las
que también debemos lidiar dicho esto
veamos algunas sugerencias para comenzar
primero lo primero revisa las tareas y
libros de texto de tu hijo si tienes
acceso a un portal de la escuela para
padres o alumnos ingresa para ver qué
tareas programaron los maestros de tu
hijo antes de salir de la escuela esto
te dará alguna pista de dónde comenzar
su ruta de aprendizaje si no tienes
acceso a un portal está bien puedes
elegir un curso en khan academy con base
en la edad y grado escolar de tu hijo y
hay muchas formas de navegar dentro de
él puedes iniciar con la primera lección
también hablaremos en unos minutos sobre
cómo comenzar con el desafío de curso
para identificar lagunas de aprendizaje
rápidamente o puedes dejar que tu hijo
decida en dónde comenzar y si elige algo
que consideras que es demasiado fácil
está bien las habilidades de las
matemáticas iniciales son los cimientos
para las matemáticas más avanzadas y no
es necesariamente malo que tu hijo
repase ese material gane confianza y
mantenga al cerebro en forma mientras
estamos en estos momentos realmente
inusuales finalmente para los
estudiantes de preparatoria en los eeuu
que están inscritos a cursos de ape o
estudiando para los exámenes del sat en
khan academy tenemos los cursos ape más
populares y también tenemos nuestra
práctica oficial del sat es un recurso
increíblemente valioso pero un mantra
que puede funcionar en estos momentos es
este cualquier aprendizaje es mejor que
ningún aprendizaje no permitas que lo
perfecto sea enemigo de lo bueno hay
muchas cosas que ahora están demandando
tu atención solo comienza es muy fácil
corregir el rumbo cambiar la ruta de
aprendizaje y hacer ajustes a medida que
avanzas en khan academy ahora saltemos
hasta lo que sucede ya que estás
registrado esto es lo primero que verás
se te ofrecerá la oportunidad de
personalizar el aprendizaje de tu hijo
solo tienes que seleccionar su grado
escolar y ver los cursos que
recomendamos pero independientemente de
nuestra sugerencia tu hijo puede elegir
cualquier curso de khan academy hacia tu
hijo realmente le gustan las matemáticas
tiene un desempeño general por encima de
su grado escolar y le gustan los retos
puedes elegir cualquier curso que sea
adecuado para él o ella lo mismo en el
sentido opuesto si más bien le cuesta
trabajo no es necesario ceñirse a las
sugerencias del grado escolar una vez
que hayas elegido un curso puedes elegir
más de uno y siempre puedes regresar te
y agregar más es así como se verá la
experiencia de aprendizaje de tu hijo
los cursos siempre aparecerán en la
página de inicio siempre que se conecten
y podrás ver que khan academy está
diseñado para darle a tu hijo capacidad
de acción para decidir a dónde ir para
realizar su siguiente tarea esto puede
ser muy bueno si tienes un hijo que se
siente involucrado y motivado permítele
elegir como él quiera en el orden que
despierte su interés y energía
puede ser desafiante y un poco abrumador
tener muchas opciones cuando tienes un
niño pequeño una de las cosas que nos
gusta hacer cuando estamos en el salón
con niños pequeños es decir les sigue el
botón azul puedes ver aquí la flecha
roja que apunta a un botón azul de
empezar está por lo general es una muy
buena opción básicamente para que el
niño siga de manera lineal el curso
comenzando con las habilidades más
básicas y avanzar desde ahí siempre es
una buena opción si quieres darle a tu
hijo una idea de hacia dónde dirigirse
después una vez hecho esto cuando le das
click a alguna de estas unidades
aparecerán las lecciones estas incluyen
instrucciones prácticas y evaluación
las flechas rojas que ves aquí señalan a
la derecha el ejercicio práctico y a la
izquierda los recursos didácticos si en
la práctica tu hijo siente que el
material representa un reto pero no
tanto como para querer cambiar de nivel
podrá encontrar un artículo o vídeo
o una serie de artículos y videos justo
al lado de la práctica que lo apoyará a
medida que practica y refuerza sus
habilidades otra cosa que queremos
mencionar es el desafío de curso la
mayoría de nuestros cursos de
matemáticas tienen este desafío y es una
gran forma de acelerar el proceso para
que tu hijo llegue a ese conocimiento
que se le está complicando un poco de
una manera productiva pero lo suficiente
como para no desalentar lo y la forma de
hacer esto es desplazarte hacia abajo
hasta el final de la página del curso
ahí encontrarás este botón que dice
comenzar el desafío de curso lleva algo
de tiempo reserva 30 o 45 minutos para
que tu hijo lo realice el resultado
final te dará una idea de las
habilidades en las que se siente más
cómodo y aquellas en las que necesita
más práctica especialmente en la etapa
del año escolar en la que estamos esta
es una muy buena opción para ti ya que
habrá mucho contenido que le será
familiar en la mayoría de los casos por
esta razón comenzar desde el principio
puede no ser siempre lo que necesites
la única advertencia que podríamos hacer
es que a menos que tengas un hijo cuyo
desempeño es regularmente alto el
desafío de curso puede sentirse un poco
como un examen para el que no se ha
estudiado a menudo frente al desafío los
estudiantes tienen la mentalidad de
tener que sacar buena calificación pero
el objetivo de los desafíos de curso es
identificar las áreas en las que se
necesita más práctica por lo que como
padres
necesitamos apoyarlos y hacerlos sentir
cómodos con la idea de que esto no es un
examen y que no deben preocuparse por la
calificación y de lo que realmente se
trata es de encontrar la mejor forma de
aprovechar khan academy khan academy
está diseñado para que sea una agradable
experiencia para tu hijo mientras
practica celebramos con confetti cuando
sube un nivel hay campanadas cuando
tiene una buena racha
habrá una agradable sorpresa cada vez
que responda correctamente y hay vídeos
y pistas que ofrecen apoyo inmediato en
khan academy realmente tratamos de
celebrar no solo subir de nivel también
la determinación y la perseverancia
porque eso es tener mentalidad de
crecimiento ahora hablaremos brevemente
acerca de las herramientas para padres a
las que tendrás acceso dentro de tu
cuenta de padre lo más importante que
vas a hacer cuando estás registrado como
padre es ver el progreso de tu hijo este
informe equivale a estar en la misma
habitación que él mirando por encima de
su hombro lo que está haciendo viendo en
que está trabajando pero sin realmente
mirar sobre su hombro es como una
auditoría que te muestra cada ejercicio
cuánto tiempo pasó en cada uno y como lo
hizo hay tres valores que pueden ser de
mucha ayuda para apoyar a tu hijo y
motivarlo en su trabajo aquí verás dos
números uno es el tiempo que pasa
haciendo los ejercicios que es realmente
la práctica en donde aplicar a sus
habilidades y el otro es el tiempo total
de aprendizaje en khan academy que
incluye ver vídeos y leer artículos es
importante buscar una mezcla de ambas
cosas no solo de enseñanza sino también
de práctica y el tercer valor son estas
pequeñas flechas verdes que puedes ver
aquí en la pantalla estas se indicarán
si una habilidad
está subiendo o bajando de nivel esto
significa básicamente que tu hijo está
avanzando hacia el dominio de esa
habilidad dominio parece un término muy
elegante pero realmente quiere decir que
tu hijo está logrando ser tan bueno en
esta habilidad que puedes ser capaz de
explicársela a alguien más casi podría
enseñarla habrá también flechas rojas
cuando el niño tiene dificultades y
quizá esté bajando un nivel en esa
habilidad y esta es tu oportunidad para
decirle mira vamos a revisar esto un
poco más quizá puedan ver algunos videos
y complementarlos con enseñanza antes de
pasar a otro tema queremos hablar acerca
de cómo motivamos y estructuramos el día
del estudiante
enfrentémoslo es difícil hay muchos
distractores que buscan la atención de
tu hijo en estos momentos y no digamos
la tuya pero sea amable contigo mismo
vale la pena recordar que por supuesto
queremos que nuestros hijos sigan
aprendiendo pero pasaremos juntos en la
misma casa mucho tiempo con lo que lo
más importante es llevarse bien
en cuanto a establecer metas es buena
idea incluir a tu hijo en el proceso va
a estar más comprometido de esa forma
vayan un día a la vez si las metas que
establecieron para el primer día
resultaron no ser necesariamente
realistas dada la situación se flexible
no seas duro contigo mismo
todos estamos atravesando un territorio
desconocido y reconoce los logros nos
gusta celebrar tanto el progreso como el
esfuerzo cada vez que revises estos
números aprovecha para felicitar a tu
hijo por su esfuerzo luego vean los
niveles que ha subido como un indicador
del progreso que está haciendo por
último hemos publicado horarios que
pueden ayudarte a tener un poco más de
estructura que ayudará a tu hijo a estar
tranquilo a tener un sentido de
previsión y a ti te dará espacio para
maniobrar ya que tendrás una idea de
cómo irá tu día te invitamos a
revisarlos en sigamos aprendiendo punto
khan academy punto o hereje
en sigamos aprendiendo punto khan
academy punto o hereje diagonal u s si
estas en los eeuu y esperamos que te
sean útiles para darle estructura y
orden a tu hijo en este que parece ser
un tiempo caótico y con eso terminamos
gracias por darte el tiempo de ver este
tutorial